every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bear that
you'd be fine
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalists podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and
what you're about to hear is a live
version of our podcast which Ryan and I
recorded in beautiful Salt Lake City
Utah but first I have three yes three
exciting updates for you number one
minimalism on iTunes and Amazon yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes we heard you
loud and clear so later this month on
September 30th 2016 minimalism a
documentary about the important things
is finally coming to iTunes and Amazon
and if you pre-order the film on either
one of those platforms it really helps
us reach more people because both of
those sites use these strange complex
algorithms to recommend films for
example I'm sure you've seen if you like
that film then you'll like this film
right that's really based on an
algorithm and apparently a significant
part of their algorithm involves the
number of pre-orders a film has which
indicates popularity or whatever to the
robot overlords in their cloud Kingdom
anyway if you want to see the film on
iTunes or on Amazon we'd be grateful if
you'd preorder it today that way it will
show up in your inbox once it is
released on September 30th and of course
our robot overlords will all be pleased
with us of course you can watch the film
today on Vimeo just visit minimalism
film.com and click on see the film
that's also where you'll find all the
iTunes and analyst
on pre-order lengths but no matter how
you see the film or where you see the
film we really hope you find value in in
this creation we spent a ton of time and
resources on this film and now people in
110 countries have watched the film and
so we'd love to hear what some of your
favorite scenes are just share them
using the hashtag minimalism film on
social media
all right update number 2 our TEDx talk
in less than 2 weeks more than 100,000
people have seen our second TEDx talk
which is called the art of letting go
have you checked it out yet if not you
can find it over on our YouTube channel
which is just youtube.com slash the
minimalists third and finally the last
writing workshop of 2016 ok I'm hosting
this year's final how to write a better
one day online workshop which is
basically I stripped down the version of
my four-week class it's on Sunday
October 30th and I don't have any plans
yet for next year so it'll be a while
this would be the last one for a while
at this point and it's recorded so if
you can't it's in the live class don't
worry you can obviously watch it
afterwards still have access to all of
the the resources afterward as well find
all the details over at how to write
better dot-org oh and just a heads up
seats are limited ok that's it for the
updates for now I hope you enjoy this
version of the minimalists podcast and
one of my favorite cities in the world
Salt Lake City Utah and stay tuned after
the broadcast for some minimalism tips
from our listeners well hello everybody
welcome to a special LIVE version of the
minimalist podcast I'm Joshua fields
Millburn and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and we
are live tonight in Salt Lake City Utah
Wow you you all are awesome so thank you
so much we have a microphone somewhere
where folks can ask questions usually
the way that we do this podcast is we
take voicemails and it'd be really weird
if I had you all like call us up right
now and so instead of doing that we'll
have you just come on down and answer
questions there's a microphone right
here in the middle as soon as you get
there a spotlight will dawn on you and
someone has to break the ice at some
point in time though otherwise I'll just
sit up here an interview Ryan okay
sometimes you have to go backwards to go
forward on the road we call that a faux
fun dirty because it sounds really
profound but it literally means nothing
so just give us your name and whatever
your question comment concerns I'm a
yoga teacher and I teach people about
meditation so I really appreciated this
on multiple levels and kind of came away
with a different take away than I
thought I would coming in so my question
would be with a different take away
well I was under the impression that it
was gonna be one of those things where I
was like dang it I do need to get rid of
my book collection but that's not how I
felt you know it was it was very
interesting to say to see how I value
the objects that I do have in my life so
that kind of leads into my question that
I have for both of you and obviously
there's going to be different answers
from anyone in this room but I'm just
curious to know what your perspective is
and you talked a lot about the values
and the opportunity that you gained from
from minimizing your stuff but I'm
curious to know what each of you has to
say about what your relationship with
the things that you do have is well I
will tell you uh you know getting rid of
the stuff is the initial bite at the
Apple it's like that that was a great
first step for me but what that really
led into was discover
or making room for the most important
things in life making room for what I
wanted my priorities to actually be so
you know it's I spent so long saying oh
you know my health is really important
but then like I'm always you know
getting McDonald's and Burger King and
and not you know exercising regularly or
I'd say my relationships those are
really really important but I would see
my mother maybe you know five or six
times a year and I only lived about a
half hour away from her because I was
too busy to focus on that but but you
know our priorities are what we what we
do not what we say we do and so getting
rid of the stuff helped me to to realize
like wow if I stop focusing on having
this big house having this car bringing
in all of these items I can actually
make room make the time to do those
things not not keep lying to myself or
you know planning to do that when I
retire one day I could take control a
lot sooner than that so I mean the stuff
I have now everything I have it adds
value and when I mean by that is it
serves a purpose or it brings me joy I
don't keep a catalogue of my stuff I
couldn't tell you how many items I own
that is that is not that's just not my
version of minimalism and like you said
everyone kind of has their own their own
version but the relationship I have with
my stuff now my physical items it's
their tools their tools in my life that
I use and there are things that I have
that Josh does not have and vice versa I
mean I snowboard and there's a lot of
equipment that comes along with
snowboarding Josh doesn't have those
things cuz they would just sit in his
closet and collect us they would kill me
that's why I don't have those things so
I mean that's how I've used stuff now
people often ask like if you were going
to or if your house caught fire and you
could only grab you know one or two
items like what would you grab and I'm
thinking like my girlfriend my cat well
it's really her cat I guess it's kind of
work out but uh but yeah you know like
that's that's kind of what comes to mind
but everything else I mean
you know if Mariah called me right now I
was like oh honey the apartment caught
fire and everything's gone and then I
was like oh that really stinks and then
like I hung up my phone and then my
phone like disintegrated I mean I would
not I don't have attachment to those
things anymore because over the last six
years I've been working so hard
incorporating good habits into my life
to not develop those attachments that
that are that are hard too hard to sever
I can kind of sever that attachment
pretty quickly now so yeah that's how I
view the things in my life currently is
just just tools yeah I would just say
that I no longer give the same meaning
to stuff that I once did I used to give
stuff so much meaning my material
possessions they they meant something to
me whether it was the 2000 books that I
owned some of which I actually had read
other others of which I planned on
reading one day and some non-existent
hypothetical future and and yeah I'd go
to the bookstore and buy four or five
six books at a time and you do that
enough and you just amass this huge book
collection and I realized that I was
holding on to that because people will
come over and say wow that's a beautiful
bookshelf you have with all these books
and I realized that I had an attachment
I gave meaning to wow people think I'm
smart from that and it was a way for me
to to put up this facade this veneer of
intelligence as opposed to just caring
less about the image I tried to project
onto the world and simply be myself and
I found I was doing that with a lot of
stuff well there was the luxury cars
that I had cars
plural the he the big suburban house
with more toilets than people you know
all of these things that I held on to
because I gave it some meaning and now
the stuff that that I have like Ryan I
use it as a tool but I'm also prepared
to walk away from it at any time and I
live by that principle in fact one of my
favorite things
I've ever written was an essay called
the things were prepared to walk away
from I don't know if you read it but
it's in our book called essential I
don't wanna feel like I'm selling you a
book so I'd love to give you a copy of
the book afterward I think Sean has some
around here somewhere
so we're gonna copy that but basically
that the principle goes like this has
anyone here seen the movie heat with
Robert De Niro and Al Pacino there's a
few of you right yeah ok so there's a
sort of bad guy character in the movie
and he talks about being willing to walk
away for never bring anything into your
life that you're not prepared to walk
away from in 30 seconds flat is the line
verbatim now I don't live by that
prescriptively
but I think it's a good guiding light to
look at anything in my life being
willing to walk away from the material
things and being able to walk away from
those at any point in time because that
forced me to continue to ask the
question does this add value to my life
the things that add value to my life may
not add value to my 40 year old self or
my 50 year old self so I have to keep
asking that question minimalism isn't a
destination you don't get down to your
1,000 items or 100 items or like Colin
in the film you don't get down to your
52 items and all of a sudden you're the
ultra minimalist and now you're happy
it's a moving target for you and the
things I bring into my life now augment
that experience as opposed to having
some sort of made-up meaning that I'm
projecting onto them that's my short
answer
hi my name my name is miles my first
question is I notice there are a lot of
good-looking people in the film I wanted
to ask you out the hypothesis that being
a minimally make you more attractive we
had to balance it out because we had to
put me and Ryan in the film and then we
got a bunch of good-looking people in
the film as well yeah that's and I've
never even considered the you should
think about that good the minimalism
yeah it I have fewer gray hairs now and
people tend not to believe me when I say
that but when I was 27 I was working 80
hours a week I was stressed out of my
mind and I remember after after I
started simplify my life I never jumped
up and said look at me I'm becoming a
minimalist and or or especially didn't
say look at me I'm getting rid of all
this stuff cuz then what do people say
are you gonna kill yourself instead it's
so weird that the sort of telltale sign
of suicide is like removing excess stuff
from our lives that's the culture that
we've we've we digressed wait that
wasn't a real quality I mean you should
really think about it I used to take
some time let me finish my long
circuitous answer here here's what I'll
say though I'm there were people at work
coming to me after like six months eight
months if I'd been simplifying my life
and toward the end of that people that
work started saying hey man what is
going on with you you seem so much less
stressed you seem so much calmer what is
going on you seem so much nicer and I
realized that like these were like
additional benefits I didn't necessarily
expect when I first embraced yeah
simplifying my life so I'll let you ask
your real question happier people will
come across as more attractive and I
think that those people are happier
because they have instituted this
philosophy into their life and yeah
I agree that yeah it certainly could
help make you happier which by default
might make you a little bit more
appealing to others I guess yeah I mean
also good casting but I don't know what
which which came first but I do like
that so the question I have is you talk
a lot about stuff and you're in your
previous answer it was all about stuff
and there were parts of the of the movie
that for lack of a better word were a
little bit like I thought of the time
disjointed like they skipped around a
lot but as I'm thinking about it I guess
my question is how do you connect
minimalism or can you tell me talk a bit
about minimalism in stuff that's not
stuff so so there was one part where one
of your interviewees talked about how
often we look at our cell phones I think
that might be a good example but in what
other ways is Minos ISM not just about
stuff sure I think for me it starts with
the stuff the the material possessions
are often a a physical manifestation of
what's going on inside us but by
clearing the sort of excess stuff that's
going on around us we're able to start
dealing with what's going on inside us
so by by getting rid of the excess stuff
the average American household has
300,000 items in it and the truth is
some of those things actually do add
value to our lives right many of those
things make our lives better the problem
with me was I didn't know which of those
300,000 items and what percentage of
them did add value to my life and now
the paradox as a minimalist is the
things that I own now I get far more
value from those things than if they
were watered down by 300,000 items and
having all these things in the way but
then after the stuff is when it led to
all these other areas in life and Ryan
and I wrote about this in our first book
it's a book called minimalism love a
meaningful life again don't want to sell
you a copy so I'd love to give you a
copy afterward and basically after
removing those things I realized that I
didn't even know what was important in
my life anymore I'd gotten to that point
where these things I thought were
important important so-called success
and achievement and the trinkets of
success the the accumulation of
like that wasn't important to me anymore
and so I needed to figure out what was
important and so Ryan and I came up with
these five areas in life that we
identified there were these sort of
higher-order values we called them the
five values of living a meaningful life
the first one's health you know I used
to weigh 80 pounds more than I weigh now
and I wasn't just fat like I felt like
crap and so it affected all other areas
in my life
the second area was relationships I said
my relationships were a priority but I
didn't treat the people closest to me as
though they were a priority to me it's
the reason my marriage ended I I I
forsook the relationships closest to me
and instead spent a ton of time with
those secondary or tertiary
relationships especially those tertiary
relationships co-workers acquaintances
networking buddies executives these
types of people there was nothing wrong
with those people just many of them
didn't share my my values or my beliefs
or my interests my desires and I
realized that because I was allocating
all my time to those folks
I wasn't allocating to the time the time
to the people closest to me a third area
we talked about and in that book was
passion or you might say craft or
creativity something like that but
focusing on what you're passionate about
cultivating something into a passion
finding something that aligns with your
values and and finding a way to be
passionate about that or creative in
that way and the last two areas go
together
growth and contribution I found that I
really wasn't growing and what I was
doing in my life before and and because
I wasn't growing I felt like I didn't
have that much to give I wasn't
contributing to my community I wasn't
contributing to the world in a
meaningful way and I find that by
stopping the focus of on the stuff I was
able to start focusing on those five
areas and I am really only as strong as
the weakest link there and really you
could call it a meaningful life for just
a well-balanced life I find that if I'm
ever feeling discontented I have to go
back to those five areas
say okay what am i forsaking now because
you can have four of those areas but if
you don't have your health and you
really don't have anything or if you
don't feel like you're contributing to
the world well you're gonna feel very
sellable Cystic and and really like a
parasite in a way and so I fine I always
have to go back to those five areas and
question you are my actions that I'm
doing today are my short term actions
aligned with my long term values and I
think that leads to happiness yeah I'll
tell you though I don't think happiness
is the point and I think we we get
confused with that alive we chase
happiness and I in fact I think
discontent is a byproduct of chasing
happiness and in fact I found that by
living a meaningful life I was able to
be happy without chasing that thing
called happiness and then yeah I would
say it bled into other areas of life to
technology we did a whole podcast
episode about about technology and and
just talking about you know cutting that
which is superfluous digital clutter and
things like that and you start to ask
the same question that you asked about
your stuff does this add value to my
life you start to ask that about
virtually everything from technology to
relationships to the way we're spending
our time to you entertainment we consume
etc
all right I had a couple questions but
uh I'll narrow it down to maybe four now
first and foremost like you guys have
been doing this for how long about six
years six years do you guys ever feel
pressure to maintain an example of what
you guys are doing or is it just
literally become who you are yeah for me
it's literally become Who I am I would
say that this is a great way to help me
stay motivated to to keep on this on
this road but but ultimately you know I
don't find myself making decisions based
on oh my god what are my readers gonna
think about this decision that never
pops into my head if anything pops into
my head it's man Ryan you really want to
be a good example don't you and and you
know doing this is gonna be a good
example not just for everyone who reads
our stuff not just for you know the the
12 year old you know kid who I just met
walking out of the of the screening or
you know the high school kids that show
up or the college kids or whatever it's
it's it's am I gonna be a good example
for myself to kind of like what Josh
said you know now I find myself striving
to be the best like 40 year old version
of myself
so whether you know we had the
minimalists calm or not I would still be
striving to to be the best 40 year old
version of myself so yes certainly there
is an aspect there that drives me to be
a good example but that that's not
that's a very small piece of why I do
what I do I guess I have a friend who is
that a she was a shopping mall a few
years ago and she sent me a text message
and she's like I'm getting ready to buy
this thing but I would like I'm always
thinking what would Joshua would do and
it's like the you know those little
bracelets she's like I'm gonna get one
of those bracelets this says WWJD and
the funny thing about that was I think
that's great advice but not like what
would I do
but what would you the best version of
yourself do in any scenario and so I'm
constantly asking myself what would the
best version of myself do here and
really what that means is are these
actions in line with my longer-term
values or is this a sort of short-term
pacifier that you know I'm trying to
fill some sort of void with and so yeah
I think I'm constantly trying to make
decisions as the best version of myself
and I think if I if I am being as close
to the best version of myself as I can
be then it tends to just sort of by
proxy set a good example for others I'll
tell you that's like the biggest thing I
love about this is like I feel honored
to be able to be a role model or an
example for for other people it's it's a
it is a huge honor for sure um so yeah
it definitely drives me to continue to
to be that good example but yeah it's a
good question and then my last question
sorry what's your name by the way
elijah elijah it's good to meet you
brother good to meet y'all so we live in
Utah and a lot of people have kids here
and so I know some of y'all gonna want
your kids to be like this cuz I do I
mean I was completely opposite you know
I was a
maximus the opposite of what you all are
so was i okay and I'm really literally
in my last literally about last year
I've really tried to undo that and it's
weird it's it's just naturally happening
and it's kind of cool too oh it's not
the most expensive thing anymore that I
picked out and I don't really need that
car anymore so it's a good feeling so
I'm just gonna really figure out I'm you
guys aren't parents though right yeah I
am but oh he's not okay so have you been
a parent the whole time you've know so I
guess my question is
how the how do we teach our kids that
have been taught opposite this lifestyle
Ryan since you're not a parent give him
some advice yes it's really easy for me
to give advice many kids I'll tell you
something that one of our audience
members and during our 2014 tour said
that they did what their kids which was
I thought was pretty cool so from a very
young age she has been trying to
incorporate these this philosophy these
types of thoughts with her kid and she
said you know when when her
five-year-old daughter would come home
from school with like an art project
she'd be like oh you know this is this
is what I did today and I'd really like
to hang it on the fridge is that okay
and she's like yeah we can totally put
that on the refrigerator
now the refrigerator is already covered
in our projects so they go over to the
refrigerator and she's like okay which
one would you like to take down and
replace this one with and then they kind
of go through this whole process where
the kid will pick which art project they
want to take down and then they walk
over and and throw it away sometimes she
said she would like to take a picture of
the project that they were throwing away
just so she could have it put it you
know the digital cloud but yeah I mean
certainly there's there things like that
she does the same thing with toys when
you know if the kid wants something her
big thing was is she hated and tell her
kids no so she will tell him yes as
often as possible so if you know her
daughter comes to her and says you know
I really want this toy if it's
appropriate and they can afford it
she'll say great we can totally get that
toy let's pick something else that we
can donate and have another child
benefit from so I thought that was a
pretty cool way of approaching it but
ultimately I'll say you know and joshua
becker touched on this i mean our kids
our kids kids kids are watching their
parents and and I know when I was a
child how how how closely I watched my
parents I know I have like my I have
siblings my oldest sibling is 13 years
younger than me oh I'm sorry yeah yeah
about that 12 using anything
but I know that even watching them grow
up and watching me I knew that I was
setting an example for them so
ultimately I would say your kids are
definitely watching and the better
example you can set for them and show
them the benefits of of this philosophy
and why you apply it to your life the
more app they're going to embrace it in
their own yeah I would just say what
I've learned so Ella turns 3 this week
so she's still you know toddler aged
kids are sort of naturally minimalist
man they just don't give a damn about
the the amassing of stuff but over time
of course what happens is they are
watching parents as Ryan said but
they're watching everything else that
goes on around them as well and you saw
Juliet sure kind of talk about the you
know the advertising to children and and
that whole industry which is a
multi-billion dollar industry now and
has grown exponentially since the 80s
and especially in the 90s and and since
then and and so kids are paying
attention and all of us see 5000
advertisements a day right but children
are shaped more by those but by those
bits of input then then we are it's not
that we aren't we certainly are but
they're gonna be shaped for more and the
best way to to influence them to is
here's the question your kids are gonna
get brainwashed
who's gonna brainwash them you or the
advertisements I think yeah I'll just
add one thing to going back to what
Joshua Becker said in the movie you know
you don't want to like lock your kids in
an empty room you don't want to just
like throw their stuff out as parents
you do have the ability to set
boundaries for them though so there are
certainly boundaries you can set with
the things they bring in their lives
like a one in one out type situation or
even like setting up like the type of
entertainment that they take in
kind of go until the film of how we're
talking about the newest latest greatest
always upgrading I think it could lead
to that sir I think it could certainly
lead to that that's that's I'm not
saying that every time your kid wants
something that you say yes as long as
they get rid of something else I'm just
saying that you could approach some
decisions in the household that way
certainly I think ultimately comes down
to asking and asking more questions to
find that even even with a
three-year-old I'm constantly asking her
questions why do you want that and I
sometimes the backfires and because
she's constantly asking me the same you
know questions over she asked me why a
million times a day and and so I find
that asking asking questions
quite often gets to the to the purpose
behind the want right quite often we
want something I know I certainly did
throughout my 20s I didn't know why I
wanted that second Lexus but I wanted it
and when you get down to the purpose
behind it and we train ourselves to
understand what that purpose is it if
you do that enough over time it becomes
less of an intellectual exercise well
why do you want this why does this add
value to your life and over time it
becomes a more visceral or emotional
exercise because if you program yourself
or your kids to ask these important
questions
what's my own definition of success
who's the person I want to become why
have i given so much meaning to these
material possessions questions like that
if we're programming ourselves and our
children to ask those questions more
frequently then then we're gonna be in a
much better position than if we just you
know placate them and then of course
yeah we set up some rules along the way
because that's what we need to do as
parents but asking those questions
alongside the rules I fine-fine helps me
out a lot just gonna add one more thing
no go to go to the minimalists comm
slash children and there's an essay
there that leav about a wrote for us
it's called minimalism are no excuses
minimalism with kids and there's also a
recommendation a book by Joshua Becker
that that I think will really add value
to because I always feel guilty given
advice on kids when I don't have any
kids but those are two to two gentlemen
who have pretty you know significant
families and they have wrote about wrote
about how they kind of approach it with
their children yeah Leo's the guy with
six kids minimalists comm slash children
and Leo has an essay there and Joshua
Becker's book clutter-free with kids
thank you thanks man so my name is
Landon and right now I'm in college and
I really want to share this with a lot
of my friends but the problem is a lot
of them are they're pursuing a degree to
make a lot of money sure and so let me
ask you a question I don't mean to cut
you off we know what you finish question
what's wrong with making a lot of money
there's nothing wrong with it I guess
but I don't know if they have really any
other reason for their degree except for
that
that's just like they're okay and I want
to try and share this with them but
they're hesitant are kind of cynical
because it goes against everything
they've been like kind of working
towards and so I'm wondering if you have
some advice on how to how to share this
with people who might be pretty hesitant
towards the idea yeah I can tell you I
have never recommended one of our books
or an essay without being solicited for
help so I've never like sent my mom and
I say like hey I wrote this for you mom
that you really need to read this
because you're not getting it that's
it's and Josh didn't come in to me and
say hey Ryan you got a lot of [ __ ] man
you need to read this stuff it was more
about me seeing the benefits and going
to Josh and saying dude why the hell are
you so happy what is going on man like
you just went through all this crazy
stuff like are you on drugs or what dude
and that's when he told me about
minimalism but I would encourage you to
do the same thing with with your friends
if they are asking you for help if you
see them in turmoil if you see them
stressing over over something that you
feel like you know a book or an essay or
whatever from from someone who I don't
want you just recommend our books and
essays
plenty of other books and I essays the
recommend on minimalism but if there's
an opportunity for you to help your
friend in a situation where you see that
they're having pain with then I think
that would be a perfect perfect time to
interject but yeah I agree man like just
going to someone and saying hey you know
I read this book on minimalism even
though your intentions are great and
like you're really not trying to call
them out on anything when you approach
someone when they haven't solicited for
help and you're offering them a piece of
advice they're automatically going to
feel some sort of judgement and as soon
as they feel that judgement that's where
they will start to project and that's
where they will start to get cynical
yeah how do you get your friends to play
ice hockey I mean when I think about
about that question it's like man it'd
be really difficult if I just wanted to
force my friends to start playing ice
hockey right now especially since I
don't play ice hockey but but I think
you can't really force anyone into that
situation but but if if there is if
there is an underlying discontent there
they may not see it yet it sounds to me
like like what you're saying is their
definition of success is is making more
making a significant amount of money
that's why I asked that question earlier
I don't think there's anything
inherently wrong with with making money
I think we all need to make some money
to earn a living the problem becomes
when it is our sole driver for doing
what we do and when it becomes the point
of doing what we do in fact it's we're
there's a weird thing right it's the
first question we ask when we meet
someone what do you do wow that's such
an expensive question when you really
think about it well I go to concerts i
watch movies I take long walks on the
beach oh you're asking me how much money
do I make where do I work so you can
compare me to you on the socio-economic
ladder but if we posit the question that
way we seem like a mean person
and and so instead we say what do you do
and then we spend the next 15 minutes
talking about what we do to earn a
living and if that's what you're
passionate about I think that's awesome
but but it's not always what you're
passionate about and so I think what you
do doesn't have to be what you do to
earn a paycheck and and when I think
about what I do I flip that question
around someone asked me what do you do
I say I'm really passionate about
writing I don't say I'm a writer because
then you start getting these weird
accuses the right questions who's your
publisher how many books have you
written you can make a living off that
and instead of seven really passion
about writing I said what are you
passionate about and I'll say well I'm
passionate about snowboarding or this or
that or whatever and it changed the
trajectory of our of our conversations
and someone may say I'm really
passionate about accounting and I'm an
accountant that's great and then we can
least talk about what they're passionate
about and so I find that we know if you
have friends you think you would they
would get value from from a documentary
like this or a book or whatever that
that's one of the reasons that we made
the film was during the intro we kind of
talked about we've this has become a
multimedia project for us we started up
a podcast and we have the blog and we
have books and we're just constantly
finding new ways to communicate with
people because I realized that fewer
than 50% of American males read a book a
year so so they've read less than one
book a year is the stat which to me is
zero books here so there has to be other
avenues to communicate with people so it
may not be the documentary maybe that's
too long maybe it's our TED talk I think
it's a great introduction we did a 15
minute TED talk and letting people
decide for themselves because one thing
I can't do is project this lifestyle on
to someone else I can simply provide a
recipe and that's what we're doing right
now we're not here to convert anyone to
minimalism but we want to share our
recipe in hopes that you can tweeze out
a few ingredients and maybe live a more
meaningful life because of it it's a way
that we can contribute
hi howdy well Joshua you and I actually
met last year when yeah you came too
well our book works with Colin Ryan and
Courtney Carver and you and I have the
same birthday awesome June 29th would
you give me just kidding I hope nothing
like you're a minimalist aren't you yeah
Ryan you weren't there so well actually
I just wanted to start off with a huge
thank-you cuz I was introduced to
minimalism about a year ago
you know like I came to that signing and
you know it's changed my life and you
know more ways than I can count where
it's like you know I found much more
meaningful relationships in like the
past you know six months and I did like
the two years before that and like I've
started school because I know like the
things I want to do
I found a sport that I love for like
physical activity and I'm actually
starting up a business so it's like all
this has allowed me like the time and
energy and money and clarity in order to
you know act on the things I want to do
so first want to thank you for that well
it sounds like this is like an
infomercial out here you are awesome
thank you first question it's kind of a
selfish question but what can I expect a
hug and signature from Ryan at some
point you're stealing my thunder but
we're gonna do that later tonight and
then the other question being I am
somewhat approaching the end of kind of
my um like clutter clearing journey you
know like physically mentally digitally
you know like I'm at a point I'm getting
really close to where it's like all this
stuff in my space I do like use on a
daily basis but I live with my dad and I
recognize that he comes from like a
generation of you know you you have like
all the furniture that you need then
once your parent dies off they you just
inherit everything from them as opposed
to where something I pointed out to him
is that we we kind of live in this you
know cycle of like this is something
that I got use of at this stage in my
life now I'm letting it go off to be
used by someone else
you know it's it's a cycle and so and
he's been struggling with especially
things that he's got me in the past
where I used to get used from it and I
used to love it but now it's just taking
up space and I'm not using it so I guess
advice for helping me help him see that
I'm not just throwing stuff away giving
stuff away that I'm just it's gonna find
a new purpose with someone else well I
can tell you a story about my mom that
I'm sure some people here have heard
maybe you've heard it to stop me if
you've heard this one no so my mom
called me up like a month after the
website was was up and she's like hey
son how's it going like it's going great
mom what are you up to oh nothing much
what's this minimalist crap it's like oh
you found the website because like we
hadn't advertised that she must have
been googling my name or something and
she's like what is going on like are you
not gonna be around for holidays anymore
like are you depressed can I not buy you
stuff anymore like what is going on with
you and I was like well no mom I really
hope that I'll be around
not just for holidays but I hope I'll be
around more because right now that's
about the only time I see you I really
hope that I can you know use this path
that kind of help me free up some time
so I can develop our relationship a
little bit more and I said yeah yeah I
am depressed actually that's why I am in
this rut that I need to get out of that
is why I am refocusing what I'm doing
with with my time and my resources my
other resources and and I it was like
yeah and as far as buying me stuff yeah
please don't buy me anything I would
really appreciate that and she was like
okay really glad to hear you're you know
making your life better and all that I'm
still gonna buy you stuff though I'm
your mother and I suppose like she has
that right as my mom to say that I was
like okay well if you buy me something
that I can't use if it doesn't serve a
purpose or bring me joy if it's just
gonna sit and collect dust I'm going to
have to give it to someone else or
donate it I'm gonna have to find it
another home that's not the thing to say
to your mom she got pretty upset
and we started going back and forth and
eventually I just you know kind of wound
her down a little bit by just you know
saying mom I love you so much
well you love me right she's like of
course I love you and I'm like I want
you to be happy you want me to be happy
too right she's like yeah of course I
want you to be happy I'm like well if
that's the case I just need you to
support me so I was just asking her for
support you know I told her look you
don't have to have a packing party you
don't have to become a minimalist you
don't have to tidy your house up before
I come over I'm not gonna come to your
home and judge your things this is about
me living a meaningful life this is
about me really trying to be happier so
I can free up time and other resources
to do things that are important and you
are important to me and this is gonna
help me do that and that's what really
kind of got through to her so I would I
would encourage you to have that similar
conversation with your father and and
you know it's and ask him that you know
if you would just we want to support you
on this journey because it is making you
happier because ultimately he does want
you to be happy I'm sure he does all
right thanks Ryan yeah that's definitely
not an issue with my mom she's here with
me so hey if you come down here right
now I'm pretty sure Ryan will be happy
to give you a hug come on down I even
have a sharpie I'll sign your book well
I just got the wrap-up from Shawn so we
can do one more question here and then
I'll wrap it up for everyone how did
awesome
we're saying thank you as much I gained
a lot of value out of it and we were
driving up here and I thought oh I hope
this goes the podcast I hope that's as
good as they are because my sister and I
have a weekly date usually Wednesday
Thursday it's like oh if you listen to
travel and you listen to Miami so it's a
constant battle back and forth but I
have found a lot of value so thank you
so so much thank you but I started my
journey probably about a year
half ago we'd move 21 times in 17 years
of marriage three kids later okay you're
gonna say 21 times in a year and a half
that would be epic that's like that's
more than Collin raise but so I started
unpacking a lot of things and I mean I
literally and I just bought the doxy
which for those of you don't know Doxey
is a the scanner I used for it's not
like a puppy or anything it's it's a
it's a really great scanner I use so
Ryan did this thing called a packing
party you all may have heard of this he
packed up all his stuff as if he were
moving unpacked everything over 21 days
and it was an experiment and a follow-up
to that took all of my photos and and
about this this Doxie scanner too
because remember those old scanners
where you'd like lift the lid up and you
put one damn picture on there you close
the lid you go back to your computer and
ya make this the fax machine sound and
it was and some of them actually were
fax machines and and so I bought this
scanner you just feed these photos
through relatively quickly and I've
invited some friends over we had a
scanning party so this packing party and
a scanning party it turns out if you put
party at the end of anything Ryan shows
up and and so yeah we had a scanning
party I think you can read about that at
the minimalists comm slash scanning for
those of you who want more information
on the way I can I can let you finish
your question my question is do by
yourself you know kept going watching a
TV and my question is and I'm not very
techy but what digital cloud service do
you use or what have you guys done to
where you've made a very accessible
because my plan is to take all of this
to blur books and do your books for my
family but in the interim
we take it to an external hard drive
yeah
so I'll tell you what I did so first off
I and I were trying to get too much in
the weeds here but I named the files
whoever's in the picture and the
location and if I know the year I'll put
that it's not the most organized system
in the world but if it's Ryan Shawn and
Jeff then it'll say Ryan Shawn Jeff that
was 2016 that's the file name yeah and I
scanned in only the the photos I knew I
wanted I didn't scan in all my photos
but there were hundreds of them for sure
if not thousands because it's by the way
it's so much better than it I don't know
if you were anything like me but I used
to have all these photos in like a box
in the Attic a box in the basement box
and a closet somewhere and they never
get used or worse I would stick them in
photo albums and then force those photo
albums on the company yeah really the
real photos and here's the thing if you
ever have a flood fire whatever all of a
sudden all those pictures are ruined if
they're sitting in your basement and
there's your water damage or whatever
but by storing them digitally they're
not backed up forever
I do have an external hard drive that I
use and I use I use Dropbox I know that
that's the the service that I preferred
it seems to be the most intuitive but
they're all pretty similar to be honest
with you I'm not endorsing a particular
cloud service that just happens to be
the one I use and then instead of doing
the the stupid photo album I did digital
picture frames which by the way you can
upload straight from your computer now
via Wi-Fi and so you can basically scan
the photo and all of a sudden you have
this rotating photo album and now when
people come over they're like oh that
was the time you're in Hawaii they
actually care to see the photos for some
reason once you digitize it it
aggregates our eyeballs to the screen in
a way that maybe a photo album wouldn't
and so yeah that's that's what I do last
question we want to see more into your
lives as far as your child by proxy and
also your significant others is that
something
we'll see in the future yeah so Ella is
should be three and in a couple days you
can follow her on Twitter she's she has
a Twitter account kids really do say the
darndest things and then they get
tweeted she's at Ella sandwich on
Twitter and yeah I mean you'll probably
see more of that as time goes on for
sure I mean I do have a private life but
I I am okay with sharing anything that
serves the greater good and and that
tends to be where I draw my line that
there is a my online self is no
different from my in-person self just as
I have a personal life a private life
here as a private citizen but I also
have a public life here it's gonna be
the same exact thing online and so yeah
you'll you'll see more and more of that
and in the coming months for sure thanks
yeah thank you
all right before we wrap it up isn't
Nate Piper here anywhere Nate
no well so I don't did y'all like the
music in the film yeah so I gotta tell
you this every time I come back to Utah
and we go here quite a bit I feel like
I'm back amongst my people and there's a
great music scene here especially in
Provo and a journalist asked me recently
if you were trapped on a desert island
so you're pretty plausible scenario here
if you were trapped on a desert island
and you could listen to only one CD and
and I I had to tell them I don't have a
CD player but I assume this this desert
island has a CD player if you could
listen to only one CD on a on a desert
island or to be and there's a band who's
originally from Provo called parlor Hawk
and their second album is an album
called parlor Hawk
and the the lead singer that ben is a
guy named Andrew Cap'n er and the guy
who produced that album is a
grammy-nominated producer named Nate
Peiffer who also lives in Provo and I
baked them for about six months to do
the soundtrack to this film and over
that time we we became really good
friends and Andrew agreed and he got
Nate on board and they filmed a band
just for this this soundtrack and they
called it we vve and i think i think
they're releasing the soundtrack within
the next week or so when so the film
comes out and hundreds of theaters May
24th and they're gonna put the the
soundtrack out there as well but they
are there some sort of local heroes here
and I'm really grateful for their music
because I think it made the movie about
four hundred and thirty five percent
better so can we give them a round of
applause I want to say thanks and it's
really hard work going doing everything
that we do and going out in the road but
Ryan and I don't work nearly as hard as
the one man behind the scenes of all
this he's the producer of our podcast
he's the editor of our books he's our
tour manager our road manager and really
he does everything operational for the
minimalists and he's the one who also
made the bird call earlier but he's
right over here ladies and gentlemen
Sean Harding
Shawn is the hardest working man in
minimalism for sure are the folks from
Bluehost here tonight yeah we get you to
stand up real quick
there's just one of you there's two of
you all right I'm pretty sure there's
more they they had to leave and get back
down to to the Provo area so uh first
off well so we started this website the
minimalists calm like like six years ago
and when we started it we could not even
spell HTML and I remember calling Ryan
one day and saying man I cannot do this
this sucks it's not meant for me like
building a website and then we figured
out about this thing called WordPress
and we finally figured out how to cobble
together a really simple blog and we've
had a great hosting company for years
now who is hosted our our website and
the reason I tell you that is because I
called them up a few months before
starting this tour and and they're
actually based here as well well they're
at Diamond Provo and I called him up and
said hey we're about to go on this tour
and it's really expensive would you be
willing to help us out and they didn't
ask for anything but they've been really
supportive of this message of this
simple living message and getting it out
into the world and say hey we're trying
to get this documentary out to as many
people as possible and I think this tour
is gonna help us do that and so they're
really the reason we're able to afford
getting out on the road and and you know
we've been to more than a dozen cities
now bringing this document or out to
them and we couldn't do it if it weren't
for the folks over at Bluehost so I want
to say thank you so much for being a
part of this
what about this theater oh my god we've
been in a dozen theaters this is
definitely the most awesome theatre
mainly because of these recliners here
this is also they've been really great
to us and I just want to say thank you
so much to them for having us here
tonight
thank you if you enjoyed the film it
will be showing in hundreds of theaters
starting May 24th you can also request
your own screening your local theater at
minimalism film calm you just click on
see the film it's also available for
pre-order right now because this was a
sold-out screening anyone who pre-orders
the film or attends a sold-out
theatrical screening of the film is
going to get an email with 6 hours of
additional bonus interviews and content
when we went out and filmed this thing
we got about a thousand hours worth of
content now a lot of those were like
just weird sunrises and sunsets and yeah
we chanted I think every single state
throughout throughout the tour Nevada
made it but yeah there's in fact a lot
of this film as you all could see was
was filmed here in Utah and so you're
gonna get about six hours twenty or so
different interviews and extra videos
for that so stay tuned that would be out
in online August 2nd all the details for
that are at the minimalists comm slash
order if you want to preorder a copy
that but you're gonna get all the six
hours you don't have to do anything
there's no purchase required let's see
here
if you ever thought about connecting
with open-minded like-minded people
locally you can go to minimalist org
there is a free local meetup group here
in 2014 we left behind a hundred free
local meetup groups for up just people
cuz people come up to us and they say
it's great you're here for a day but now
you're leaving and I can't find anyone
locally who knows what the hell this
minimalism things about well the truth
is there are plenty of people locally
and we want to give you the opportunity
to connect with them is Jordan here
tonight the community leader yeah it
gives Jordan a round of applause
so so these meetup groups meet often
once a month sometimes more just
depending on what your schedules look
like and you can talk about whatever you
want decluttering minimalism
relationships career hair care products
whatever you whatever you're interested
in really and and you can just find all
the information to that or any of our
other cities at minimalist org let's see
here
well after after all of this Ryan and I
will be we're gonna form a line sort of
down this aisle so if you want to grab a
hug as you could see in the film they
are free now here's a little a warning
to you our hugs are much better than
they were in the film we've learned a
lot about the art and science of hugging
over the last few years especially after
reviewing the game-day tapes a bunch I
have learned that my hug was inadequate
for a long time and so you can come
judge my hug if you want to and can
maybe compare hugs and then of course
you can pass it no no wow to you it's
not and and so yeah you can come on down
grab a hug afterward we'll have some
some books here as well if you didn't
bring a wallet you can't afford a book
don't worry about it you can it's on us
feel free to grab a book afterward we'd
love to love to give you one pass it on
to someone else minimize it afterward
when you're done obviously the values
and the words not in in the artifact
itself so if you want to get a hug this
will be the line over here grab a book
if you don't want to touch sweaty sweaty
minimalists and you can just feel free
to exit whenever whenever you want and
lastly I want to thank you for being
here
you could be anywhere else in the world
tonight you chose to spend a few hours
with us and we're really grateful and if
you leave here with one message I hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for your time y'all
hi guys I am calling in response to
Anna's question on consumers and podcast
this has been in your show notes before
but I thought it was really valuable to
her question there's a great documentary
called the true cost that basically
gives us with the true cost of all those
cheap clothes that were buying is how
the fact the can use words they're made
in our environment and on the website
they have a list of clothing companies
and clothing websites that their
production aligns with the values talked
about in the documentary that's a great
place to start if you don't even know
which brands go through sweatshops or
non toxic dyes and that kind of thing
hi my name is Dorie from Portland Oregon
I had a tip about how to be a minimalist
with raising kids for a long time now we
have given our kids at Christmas time a
catalog from Heifer International which
is a organization that helps to end
poverty and empower women and children
and families in third-world countries
and so what we do is we give our kids
kids some money and then they have to
pick out a cause in the catalog so for
instance you can buy a whole goat for
120 dollars or a share of a goat for
just ten dollars so that is a way to get
the kids thinking beyond themselves and
getting the spirit of giving and they
don't end up with more stuff and it's
really they look forward to it and they
it's exciting to see what they want to
do with their money and how they pull it
together or not pull it together and I
just recommend that website h.e I ser
org thanks so much
my name is Leandro Gonzalez from Las
Vegas Nevada
I was recently listening to your podcast
about consumerism
and a woman's talk about not wanting to
use a sweatshop product I want to
clarify that and the student economics
that in a lot of these third-world
countries the alternative for these
people that work in sweatshops it's a
lot worse it could be robbery key crime
it could be prostitution so in the way
these sweatshops are actually a good
thing for their standard of living the
messiness renner things wrong I just
want to clarify that if we were to
boycott products from sweatshop
companies then a lot of those workers
would be out of work and in the worst
situation report
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without it
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you gotta grab oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tell your team
you